the numbers of scientologists have been
going down and down and down since the
early 90s is there a good I mean it's
very difficult to get to this number but
is there a good estimate of what the
current number of scientologists are
practicing scientologists is oh yeah I
did a video about this it's actually
quite easy to get to the number it's not
more than 35 000 in the entire world and
that's being very generous and
charitable that's I was intentionally
generous I broke it all down in a
spreadsheet and everything you know what
can you give like some insights of how
you get that information sure there's
about 175 to 200 Scientology
organizations in the world
anybody who's ever worked at these
organizations know there's not more than
35 to 50 staff members per org there's
not more than one to two hundred public
scientologists per org I broke down the
number of CR members who'd be working at
every Continental Management unit middle
Management International Management I
broke it on the mission network and I
was generous I mean my numbers were like
if L Ron Hubbard came back and they were
doing an event L Ron Hubbard was coming
back and announcing ot9 and 10 how many
scientologists could we scrape together
in every city to come to this event it
wasn't more than 35 000. now contrast
that to what Scientology says
Millions 10 million people
is this less people than there used to
be yeah at its peak it was about a
hundred thousand active members but
never the millions never no